[Música]
Olá que bom estarmos juntos mais uma vez
está cansado de acordar no meio da noite
sem saber o porquê descubra como vinagre
de maçã pode ser a solução que você
procura bem vamos introduzir o tema
vinagre de maçã é um produto comum na
cozinha tem benefícios surpreendentes é
feito a partir do suco de maçãs inteiras
esmagadas e fermentadas de forma acética
ou actic e recomenda-se que o vinagre de
maçã não seja pauster isado ou seja
orgânico coloca aqui nos comentários se
você consegue achar esse tipo de produto
aí na sua cidade Quais são os benefícios
do vinagre de maçã pra saúde primeiro
regulação do açúcar no sangue ele reduz
a produção de glicogênio hepático ele
diminui a concentração de açúcar no
sangue conta aqui para mim se você tem
dificuldades no controle do açúcar e
outra coisa ele regula sec de insulina e
aumenta a sensibilidade das células a
ação da insulina então ele vai
beneficiar pessoas com hipoglicemia e
também com pessoas com hiperglicemia ou
seja tantos que TM açúcar baixo como
alto no sangue Além disso o vinagre de
maçã melhor a digestão Ele ativa enzimas
digestivas no estômago e no pâncreas
protege o estômago contra
microrganismos auxilia na absorção de
minerais e vitaminas como vitamina C
vitamina K
ib12 reduz a produção de gases e alivia
o refluxo estomacal Além disso ele é
muito interessante ele vai ajudar no
controle de peso no controle do
colesterol vai ajudar a reduzir a fome
vai ajudar a perder peso e melhorar a
pressão arterial ou seja abaixar a
pressão arterial alta ajuda na liberação
de bile paraa digestão de gorduras e tem
outros benefícios surpreendentes como
combater o refluxo estacal de forma mais
eficaz que os ácidos prevenir o
crescimento de bactérias no intestino
delgado chamado cibo que é a
proliferação exagerada de bactérias no
intestino delgado ajuda na prevenção da
Resistência à insulina e também no
pré-diabetes vamos lá então como
consumir o vinagre de maçã a dosagem
recomendada é de até duas até duas
colheres de sopa em um copo com 200 ml
de água no máximo duas vezes ao dia
inicie com uma de sopa em um copo de
água uma vez ao dia e vai aumentando
gradualmente e você Você gosta do Sabor
do vinagre de maçã ou toma somente por
questões de saúde vamos falar então dos
melhores horários para tomar antes de
dormir porque ele vai reduzir os níveis
de açúcar no sangue durante a noite após
as refeições também porque ele vai
baixar a Glicemia ou seja o açúcar do
sangue e melhorar a digestão e também
vamos falar de combinações saudáveis é
interessante você adicionar gengibre ou
canela ao vinagre de maçã para
potencializar os benefícios que vai
reduzir o açúcar do seu sangue e quais
seriam as macas recomendadas de vinagre
de maçã orgânico tem várias eu vou aqui
falar de algumas o senhor vitino o São
Francisco e o da Fazenda São Roque São
boas recomendações porém é importante
ter cuidados ao consumir o vinagre de
maçã um deles é a proteção dos seus
dentes consumo esse vinagre antes
escovar os dentes e enxague a boca com
água pura após os consumo para esse
vinagre não atacar a o esmalte dos seus
dentes e é importante você escovar os
dentes meia hora depois também de
consumir o vinagre e quais são as
pessoas que deve evitar o uso do vinagre
de maçã Quais são as condições de saúde
evite se você tiver doença renal crônica
ou tiver fazendo hemodiálise e consulte
o médico ou profissional de saúde se
tiver úlcero Macau ou gastrite erosiva
antes de tomar porque essas pessoas que
TM essas condições podem não tolerar o
vinagre de maçã também suspenda o uso em
caso de desconforto ou efeitos
indesejados quando você tomar o vinagre
gostou dessa dica Salve E compartilhe
com alguém que você gosta alguém que
precisa melhorar a saúde de forma
natural conte aqui nos comentários como
foi utilizar o vinagre de maçã vamos
enriquecer esse conteúdo com a sua
experiência compartilhe os vídeos faç
bem a vida de alguém pode mudar
também
[Música]
can você é fera um grande abraço e um
beijo no seu coração